[musique]
Le premier à tuer cela fut un garçon Ben Ham de Kfar Aror
Dans un coup direct, puis deux missiles sont tombés
Il y en a un non loin d'ici qui a été tué à un kilomètre d'ici
quatre enfants, cousins ​​​​et le reste de leur famille
Blessé est un autre missile également proche de l'endroit où se trouve Rego
épouse et sa petite-fille et le reste de la famille
[musique]
ont été blessés
f Il est vrai que nous sommes assis ici, mais surtout dans le Néguev
la situation
[musique]
Nous sommes ici à un kilomètre de distance
de la légende
l'Ouest et il y a une frontière sécurisée tout le temps et il y a du trafic
du commerce entre
Les Bédouins palestiniens ont aussi des liens familiaux
Les Bédouins qui vivent de l'autre côté et les Palestiniens partent
de Cisjordanie presque librement
dans les approbations
Il y a du harcèlement envers les gens qui ont des refuges
Et nous rentrons et nous courons dehors, pourquoi
Que toutes nos maisons des villages inconnus sont
complexe
En fer, ils sont composés de toits et de robinets et s'il n'y a pas
Et à Dieu ne plaise, cela tombe sur cette maison ou une autre maison si
Un missile ou un coup tombe sur lui alors le résultat est
Le double est très difficile car le fer est très résistant
Et le fer est tranchant
est très
Anya voulait transférer les impôts à tout le monde dans le pays, comme nous le sommes.
P Droite Gauche La couche est faible La couche est bonne, nous le sommes
Ensemble, nous devrions être des préliminaires pour la veuve de Letz Pantor
que nous sommes ici et que nous sommes ici
Une veuve qui voit davantage la vie et la mer, nous avons de l'espoir
grand pour voir un horizon
Nouveau